Ok so the universe is probably infinite, and
there’s stars in every direction, and stars
are super bright.
so why isn’t it basically daylight all the
time?
Hey there my bright spots, Julian here for
DNews.
It’s an interesting question, “why is
space black?”
Well fortunately, Fraser Cain, who is brilliant
and follows me on twitter and I am not worthy,
recently discussed why we’re not wearing
shades 24/7.
Cain explains that the question was first
asked by German Astronomer Heinrich Wilhelm
Olbers in 1823.
It’s known as Olber’s Paradox, and states
that if the universe is infinite, static,
and timeless, then the night sky should be
lousy with stars.
Obviously though our night sky is more connect
the dots than pointillism.
Edwin Hubble solved the paradox in 1929.
He observed that everywhere he looked in the
universe, the spectrums of all the stars were
slightly red, meaning the light coming from
them was being stretched out, meaning the
space itself light was traveling through was
expanding.
Ergo, the universe isn’t static and there
must be stars that are so far away their light
just hasn’t had time to reach us yet.
So if we give it billions more years will
we eventually be able to tan at midnight?
Don’t hold out too many hopes, because Hubble’s
discovery of universal expansion also means
that the farther away something is, the faster
the space between it and us is stretching
out.
After a huge enough distance, space will be
stretching out faster than light can close
the gap.
There’s another facet to the paradox though.
Well, if the universe is all expanding away
from everything else, it stands to reason
that if you go far back enough, it was all
clumped together.
This is where the theory of the big bang comes
in.
But if there was a bright instantaneous flash
of existence that happened literally everywhere,
shouldn’t we be able to see that too?
Again, the riddle is solved by the expansion
of space.
In 1964 Arno Penzias and Robert Wilson were
working on a totally unrelated experiment
with a radio telescope and they couldn’t
shake this weird, unwanted static.
After making sure everything was functioning
correctly, even cleaning the inside of the
antennae for bird droppings for hours, they
realized that the signal was coming from everywhere,
and you can’t stop the signal.
They concluded that the Cosmic Microwave Background
Radiation must have been the light from the
big bang, but had been stretched out after
billions of years until it was low-energy
microwaves that our eyes can’t see.
Boom, and the universe makes sense again.
If you want to hear more possible evidence
of the big bang, trace and Dr. Ian O’Neill
talk about gravitational waves and how they
play into that over here.
What are some other implications of expanding
space?
I think it’s a great excuse to not visit
relatives, because, oh no, you’re just getting
farther away, awww dang.
Let us know in the comments and I’ll see
you next time on DNews.